I know the Quran more than anybody on
this panel you know what I'm saying I
know the Quran yeah you think you you
know more Quran than anyone on this
panel trying to tell you he says that he
knows the Quran more than anybody on
this panel don't
B bite on itce don't B leave that no
please man we got a clear rookie on the
show we got a clear rookie on the panel
go ahead and bite just leave
it problem problem watching by a rookie
so check this out how much how much no
Maurice forget that it's a red herring I
know it's a red herring it then leave
the red herring at the door leave the
leave The Logical vales door argument
being made by Ramsey Ramsey can you stop
talking but I'm talking please right
whing keep whining keep
whining Ramsey Ramsey let him respond
what the cowboy just said stay there you
said hey you as well shush embarrassing
man do you believe that Allah could have
a son if he wanted in the past so this
is the position of some of the
but that does not take you outside of
the bounds of Islam you believe in
abrogation Hosea 2:16 says what there
was a name the Lord ball that was used
in the past I have no problem with what
you're saying that if God allowed them
to call him something one time but then
say you're no longer call me this you
call me this now I have no problem with
that can you show me that example in
Islam where Allah says that yes he was a
father one time but then now he's not
okay I don't have to oh you don't have
to okay
first why is that funny I said it could
have been used doesn't mean it must have
been used even if it were used it would
not take you outside the bounds of Islam
do you have anything anything that says
that back then there was a ruling where
Allah was a no okay so that thank and
and I don't need to have
it second one second you're asking a
half truth and a whole lie because when
you say something like oh he do this and
the answer is within the Quran right
that it's not befitting for you to even
ask that question wait wait wait okay
tell me where where in the Quran does it
say it's not befitting for me to ask
this you told me that based on the Quran
it's not per permissible or befitting
that I even asked this question that no
that's not what I
said that it's not befitting for you to
even ask that question alhamdulillah and
by the mercy of Allah he is showcasing
your
stupidity it's not befitting for you to
even ask that question and and just your
embarrassment that you're bringing to
the table
here that it's not befitting for you to
even ask that question yeah so I was
asking whether or not Allah if he wanted
to could he have a son many answer with
the Quran Allah said he could I want to
know what he understood from that I if
Allah had intended to take a son he
could have chosen from what he creates
whatever he will exalted is he he is
Allah the one the prevailing what does
that tell you what nothing tell me that
he can have a son if he want it no Allah
said he could all right so supposed to
tell me opposite oh so so according to
this he can't have a son if he want it
it's a it's a sarcastic comment does
this verse say that could have a son if
he wanted is it a form of sarcas Allah
said he could so my next question to
follow up is since we know that Allah
could have a son if he wanted to could
he do it by himself or would he need
help
what is that a is that a yes he can have
a son by himself
or if you just ignored everything we
just told you so deal with the question
stop complaining about it let's go back
to 15 minutes ago I ask you what do you
mean by son you said any any sense
adopted or whatever okay could Allah
take a son and say this is my son by
himself yes so he can't have a son by
himself yes okay the verse says that
he's the originator of the heavens and
the Earth how can how can he have a son
when he has no mate okay so this is
showing that Allah has an inability to
have a son without help how do you guys
solve this I can't bro I I mean saying
that you can't is not an argument I just
can't dude I really want to hear for
your world view bro
even
without without a just like God cannot
have a husband a wife a granddaughter a
mother-in-law you know he cannot have a
son because for you to have a son you
have to have a
mate God like how your parents had sex
and and that produced you he says how
can I have a son when I have no mate
meaning in order to have a son he would
be dependent on a mate and therefore
he's not all powerful hell not
necessarily break it down how not
necessarily break it down for what type
of sun any sun you need to make a sun
period so you're talking about sun in
biological sense I don't I don't believe
that God is biological Allah is not
biological right the sun would be no it
wouldn't be it's
not biology is physical it's genetic
right so what what egg are we using here
okay is Allah physical what egg are we
using please is all our physical is
spiritual egg is all our physical that's
what I'm is a spiritual egg this will
help us walk woman giving birth to the
sun yeah is Allah physical is a woman
giv birth to the sun see this this is
where you're stuck here man I'm not
stuck mate you are well if you weren't
stuck you would answer my questions you
well you're not answering mine okay so
the egg that uh this why does there have
to be an egg does Allah need an egg to
how does a woman give birth without an
egg why does it have to be a woman why
does Allah need a woman to have a son
but this is the point that how else can
you have a biological son there it is
you see there how else can you have a
biological is Allah biological no but
how else can you you said no right so if
he were to have a son semantics right
Hamza you just said that Allah is not
biological so if he's not
biological please his son biological his
son won't be biological what do you mean
biological biological means you have DNA
it's physical you know physical makeup
that's what biology is physical makeup
yes okay so the son we're talking about
now is a son of physical makeup then yes
if Allah is physical then sure is Allah
physical talk about the sun bro talking
about Allah I'm not talking about just
the talking about the sonaran flex you
think talking about Allah's son would
Allah's son be physical that's my
question to
you as you guys can see can't none of
them deal with the arguments that we
raise because they're irrefutable they
all struggled four brains collectively
they all had a chance matter of fact
when I was dealing with two the other
two could spend their time thinking of
an answer and thinking of a response
think of a way to wiggle out of it the
best way that they can do the best thing
they think of is well according to your
belief how would I how would God have a
son then his own infinite power his own
infinite nature is the only thing
required for him to have a son according
to Islam what Allah needs the necessity
for God to have a son in Islam is he
needs a you know a little Pastime a
little thing little
mate so your God is insufficient and not
all powerful
so there was nothing and then there was
something